here's why Spotify started doing the
yearly Recaps where you got to see how
many minutes you listen to what genres
what were your top podcast now they even
give you a label so you can identify
with what type of listener you are and
so the reason they did that was they
first started introducing it and it went
super viral people shared it on all
their feeds and their stories and so it
drove a ton of attention to Spotify to
all the people who weren't on it so all
the Apple listeners and Pandora Etc had
this big fomo and so some people ended
up switching over and it was such an
effective Tac that they continued to add
to it year after year after year and you
know it's an effective tactic because
each of the other platforms is also
copied it I think one of the things that
we can take away from this as business
owners is literally just giving people
information about their own consumption
or usage is still perceived as valuable
and so if we have the opportunity to
survey them and then give them back the
data about themselves people value that
in a world that is more Quantified than
ever